this Coast in eastern England is a
protected area of outstanding natural
beauty it's also a site of bitter
dispute Britain's newest nuclear power
station is planned for here alongside
the Aging sizewell bee plant prime
minister Boris Johnson championed the
new European pressurized reactor but
planning permission for sizewell C
pushed through by his government could
now be challenged in the high court in a
case brought by a local protest group
it's on an eroding Coast if we study
long enough you'd see the cliff start to
fall away it's it's happening very very
rapidly we're in a flood zone
um this area of size world will be an
island within 100 years it's the most
inappropriate place you can imagine to
build a twin epr reactor development 12
million tons of aggregate will have to
be brought to this inaccessible place to
build the plant in the first place
Britain is facing an energy crisis as
part of its energy security strategy the
government wants nuclear to supply a
quarter of the UK's electricity needs by
2050.
sizewell c will plug seven percent of
the Gap providing 6 million homes with
electricity but critics argue it's slow
12 years to build and expensive up to 34
billion dollars while French developer
EDF and the government will together
fund 50 there's little interest from
private investors so the government is
looking to place much of the remaining
cost on taxpayers until Finance is
secured construction can't start
the other big concern is water needed to
cool the reactors this is one of the
driest regions in the country and
there's not enough capacity in the local
water supply to deliver what's needed so
EDF is proposing to build a new
desalination plant but that won't be
ready until 2026. in the meantime they
plan to truck in water four million
liters a day
EDF declined to comment the government
has weighed up the evidence that's been
exhaustive public inquiry into the
project and of course it'll be up to the
court to make that decision and from our
perspective there's an overwhelming
positive economic case and that's what
we do to support our local economy and
therefore we're fully supportive of the
scheme but the track record for building
new eprs Is Not Great projects in France
and Finland have run over budget by 200
to 300 percent and being delayed by over
a decade so while the UK's need for
energy security is urgent there are
questions over whether sizewell C is the
answer Charlie Angela Al Jazeera Suffolk